here's what i want to ask you so uh uh
in the
in ufc today okay versus 10 years ago
who's more important today
a face of the ufc that's marketable for
example usman's not marketable he's a
ridiculous fighter but is he a guy
that's going to come out and you know do
one of these why do you think usually
he's not a connor
point he's just given an example no no i
will make it very clear i think
technically the guy's a monster all-time
great but but connor yeah some people
put him in a top five conor makes you
money okay guys once in a lifetime kobe
means
kobe makes you money kobe talks [ __ ]
jorge masridal makes you money right so
chael sonnen talks [ __ ] but i don't know
was he a money yeah he was a money
fighter yeah was charles eyeballs well
i've never even heard of his name but
wait a minute but wait a minute he let
you get close he was a money fighter for
ufc but back then they didn't pay the
way it was a different uh model but he
brought eyeballs to there you go of
course he brought eyeballs to the sport
yeah so you have a point but but what
i'm trying to go to right now is the
following what what matters more
is a ridiculous one of the greatest
promoters of all time dana white more
important today to the sport of ufc or
is a great face important to the face of
us dana white okay i i agree with you i
agree with you on that look at the
business model too because now they've
gone away from pay-per-views which
pay-per-view is generated just off stars
and now they make their nut off the espn
deal getting whatever 600 million a year
put on 42 fights on espn so espn doesn't
care if it's conor or some guy you've
never heard of that's right ufc is
making their money no one's more famous
or bigger in the sport than dana white
the two most famous people aren't
fighting it's joe rogan dana white
side making very true what a great point
what a great so conor mcgregor makes a
ton of sense joining them on the outside
so this is my question for you this is
my question from kirsten what he says
who do you think okay dana's not going
to be able to do this for 30 more years
okay he's going to go for a while but to
do it 30 more years i don't know about
that is there anybody you would say
if anybody could do dana's job today
it'd be dot dot dot is there anybody
that could do his job today not to the
level that he does it at um because i do
think you ought to be kind of a shark
because a lot of fighters are pretty
caring despite what people think so
um but it'd be a fighter it'd be like a
guy like brian stan if you know who he
is military background and he went on
he's working for some huge venture
capital company now he's like the head
of it making all this money a guy like
tim kennedy who's uh who's a special
forces guy
who's brilliant but also caring would
probably take care of the fighters a
little better um daniel cormier dominic
cruz somebody what an angle you took
yeah so so you're saying fighters as
tough as they are deep down inside their
kids they're they're sensitive they want
to be able to have somebody that cares
about them that takes care of you i
think you need some of that in today's
world because dana's a businessman and
which i get you know people won't
complain about fighter pay or you know
could you know complain about things but
then we all have apple phones yeah
complain about the way you know apple
treats our employees yeah i wonder like
when you're saying that i look at it
from a maybe a different angle because
of being a business myself
no i'm not thinking straight let me give
you my insight i want you to push back
and see uh what angle you see this so i
look at uh
roger goodell okay
who likes roger goodell who hates roger
goodell okay roger goodell just signed a
godfather killing ridiculous contract
making 25 million a year private jet for
the rest of his life and you know health
all this stuff that he negotiated and he
got it right
so what do you know this this and we've
had the conversation about the guy and
the next thing you know
all the owners made boom they love them
but here's the point though here's a
point
if you think about the fact that the
owners made that money who else makes
that money
mahomes gets a half a million dollars it
trickles down right so all i'm thinking
is i think sometimes
at the top
you need an sob like a dana white that's
going to be able to sit down with these
other media bullies that's going to push
you right here i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] who you are you ain't going to be
able to bully this guy versus the other
guys are more compassionate the proper
corporate guys that are going to be
diplomatic it's like hey you know yeah
let's do side deal wink wink i don't
think dana does any winkling deal he's
not doing anything yeah that's a good
point
you need a savage in there and
unfortunately you know to to make
anomaly crack some eggs and that's what
the ufc does this is the only thing i
disagree with that's a good point this
is the only thing i disagree with that
right there there can only be so much
circus there has to be some go to go
with the show like
meaning like it's not going to turn into
bare knuckle fighting and it's just
whoever the two best [ __ ] talkers and
these guys are going to fight we're
going to make this bmf belt like they're
getting past that there's still people
that want to see gsp fight there's still
people that want to see kamarulisman
fight there's still people that want to
see the best in the world
but i'm not just talking about ufc or
boxing like look jake paul he's
disrupting that's great but when every
influencer in the world starts throwing
wild hands and hugging each other i mean
there's the sweet science is something
that's beautiful to watch because none
of us can do it for sure you know what
i'm saying so you saw when the tick tock
youtube challenge that thing was
disastrous
right you saw you know what i'm talking
about
you'll pay 200 to watch somebody in the
nba play because they do things that you
can't do you won't pay five dollars
that's what i'm saying so that's why
nobody goes to wnba on a certain on a
certain level they're pushing and
they're pushing and they're pushing but
i think they're going to kill the golden
goose the further they get away and
who's the golden goose well dude right
right now i think the nba is doing the
worst job possible by far boar's job
possible they they hate their fans look
at the ratings they they actively hate
their fans and they're filled with
superstars that's the thing so i mean
they're alienating their fans yeah their
fan base by doing some of the political
stuff they did and it's also when they
did it they're not doing it now you're
saying you're circling i don't know i
don't agree with them no they're still
kind of doing a little bit yeah they
really [ __ ] them and then the
analytics too man i mean the analytics
look i get it like i the whole reason i
had an opportunity with the cardones was
because of moneyball like you know i
struck out a lot and then i hit the ball
to the moon and that's all i did so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you